thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth new work that they really
love and create actual amazing
relationships we're so glad you're with
us America George Campbell Ramsey
personality and co-host of the ever
popular smart money happy hour with
Rachel Cruz is my co-host today open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five and uh big
announcement day George
it's here you're doing it it's National
Hug Your Dog Day that's right Dave it's
a real thing you can't make that up but
in bigger news today we launched the
George camel YouTube channel
for the first time in history camel with
a K that's right and this is big we've
been working on this now for a year or
two I've done previous podcasts here
like borrowed future and fine print and
smart money happy hour and we've kind of
combined them all into this new YouTube
channel where we expose the toxic system
we it's eye-opening it's informative
it's funny it's snarky and above all
snarky very snarky this the snarky is
it's on brand for me it's like a it's
well it's like a spiritual gift for you
thank you I mean it's it's fabulous tell
that to my wife absolute fabulous snork
so we are having a blast with this the
first video launched today on how I
bought a house with no credit score and
the reason we launched this Dave is
there's so many creators out there on
Tick Tock and YouTube and Instagram
reels and they're peddling Financial
crap to our listeners our audience and
they're sending me messages going well
to all of America yeah that you have to
go get a credit card to get a credit
score to get a mortgage for instance
or you you know there are actually
people that think that Sofi is good for
you but it actually causes a kind of an
allergy if you hadn't noticed that's it
right there get some Claritin for Dave
yeah every time he has to mention that
company and you know this Dave I had
fallen for every Trend and trap when I
first started here back in 2013 I was
forty thousand dollars in debt and I
went from negative net worth to Baby
Steps millionaire in under a decade
following our proven plan and so now I'm
just screaming from the rooftops going
guys don't listen to the get rich quick
the crypto Bros don't listen to the
whole life insurance people the the zero
down real estate folks there's a simple
way to build wealth where you have
freedom and peace and joy in your life
well we've decided with stuff like Tic
Tac and YouTube that
um we either are going to fill up those
spaces with the correct information or
just tolerate that the BS will continue
there and so what we're going to do is
try to put so much good real and helpful
information out there that is not trying
to get rich quick off of you that it
fills up the space it displays there's
no room in your social media day for any
more uh Tic Tac Warlords of crypto
that's a good way to put it the crypto
Warlords and there's so much which is
kind of teeny and small right now
there's not much lifted up there no
they're they've dissipated today they
got real quiet kind of shrunk down to
Honey I Shrunk The crypto Bros they've
been real quiet since the crash weirdly
and so of the celebrities that have been
peddling it so we break down all the
complex topics we make it simple we bust
money myths with actual facts we take
all the boring Financial stuff that's
important and we make it fun and that's
the whole goal of this channel is just
to intersect into that world of YouTube
and we built a set downstairs that's
really cool we're having a great time
with it and so everyone can go check out
the very first video right now on the
George Campbell YouTube channel uh check
that out Dave won't mind if you leave
the show right now he's got enough views
here we need you guys over there yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're doing fine
you're the co-host
you're right I apologize keep watching
the show you'll have plenty of just make
a note later make a note when you finish
here you should go to George camel with
a K on YouTube and see his new YouTube
brought to you by Ramsay networks so
thank you it's not really a net loss if
they leave here and go there but they
should do both that's right okay they'll
both be here it's on demand live in a
world where you can get it anytime yeah
it turns out YouTube is there for a
while anyway that's how it works folks I
think it's going to be great you're
going to love it I've seen a bunch of
the um
the episodes so far that we already have
got in the can and their MZ networks
team has made the best of George
George's uh world-class snark and uh
taking down the uh taking down some of
the big Liars the Liars there's so many
out there David hey grinds your gears
and it grinds mine too I'm sick of it
you're you're just I'm just kind of mean
but you're kind of funny
I'm just lost I've just lost patience
for these Crooks but you're just you're
kind of funny about it and so it kind of
destroys them in a different way that's
my version of bull I'm not big enough to
bully people so I have to get at them
with verbal abuse Dave that's how you
crack them so you get them to shut up
all right Cynthia is with us in
Minneapolis to start this hour off hey
Cynthia welcome to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon afternoon how can we help
I'm calling um so when my children were
born I wanted to help them out and me so
I bought life insurance and
um I was looking through them just
recently and I found out that it was
whole life insurance oh my and I paid
yeah I paid for them yearly and it was
it doesn't seem like a whole lot but I
didn't know what I should do with it
currently if it was just best to
surrender it now or what to do wait till
they're 20 to surrender it I would
surrender it don't you love that
terminology by the way of surrender like
you've lost a battle with these whole
life people yeah the truth is since
Cynthia you were you were sold on this
lie that you need life insurance for
your kids but the only reason for life
insurance is to replace your income so
unless those kids are providing an
income that you need you can get rid of
that and you were sold it not as that
but as an investment and as an
investment it sucks s-u-c-k sucks
it's bad it's really bad they're they're
not going to make it out of the driveway
with the money you make there much less
all the way over to the college campus
okay great thank you so what we'll do is
to repurpose the money in your budget
once you cancel this crap to uh making
sure a that you have the right amount of
term insurance on you and your husband
and so something happened to you that
the kids are provided for and B if we're
going to invest for the kids let's
invest in like a real investment like
mutual funds on a 529 and that would be
it baby step five and get in touch with
one of our smartvester pros at
ramseysolutions.com if you haven't done
that or if you don't have an investment
advisor but the 529 is going to be a
much more efficient yeah and that whole
life is such a trap and the fact that
it's sold to parents as an investment
for your kids just makes me even more
angry and there's a sunk cost because
you've been paying into it yeah it's
just gone and you go well we've already
paid so much should we just keep it
George when you're doing all this snarky
stuff on your new YouTube Channel please
point out the fact that if you will take
half a moment and think about where the
company is coming from meaning who they
are that's coming at you
um and you'll go oh what environment is
this in because it kind of I mean like
here's a point okay
Gerber
baby food company
sells Gerber Whole Life policies to send
your kid to college oh boy now it's kind
of a Jeff Foxworthy joke right you might
be broke you might be stupid if you buy
your investments from a baby food
company
same kind of thing if your investment is
advertised on a cable TV station where
they also sell Snuggies and walk-in
bathtubs then maybe your investment
sucks
it might be you know that that kind of
stuff I mean the environment the company
the background should give you a little
bit of a clue sometimes not her but just
in general yes just think about it for a
second this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thanks for joining us America George
camel with a K Ramsey personality host
of the brand new YouTube channel by the
same name launched today is my co-host
today here on the Ramsay show our
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
after fires or floods their rainbow
restoration Pros offer homeowners
trusted full service restoration
expertise like mold remediation carpet
cleaning odor removal and more visit
neighborly.com today to find rainbow
restoration services in your area
today's question comes from Caleb in
Georgia what do you think about the new
fed now and centralized banking that's
soon happening in the U.S what I
commonly see is that they're gunning to
take away cash which goes against a lot
of what your program games are for
please correct me where I'm wrong I'm
still learning more about it but I'm
curious to see what you have to say
well the uh fed has announced this and
there are really two components of it
that matter
um the first one is is that they're
going to
modernize an Antiquated banking system
today when you uh for instance deposit a
check it takes three to ten days for
that check to clear the other bank
in a digital world that should take
three to ten seconds
for your check to be bouncing or good
when I when I put your check in my
account or vice versa or I make a
transfer to your account it shouldn't
have to sit there
three days to be verified it ought to be
able to just reach over to the other
bank find out if you've got some
freaking money in there and take it out
and move it over to the your bank that's
how that's how a check is supposed to
work and that system is operating like
the 1930s right now and they're trying
to move it into the digital world that
is as far as I can tell 100 positive
what I understand of it the second piece
is they're talking about issuing
digital dollars
which they already do so I don't
understand
uh I mean they're not saying they're
going to do away with cash they're
saying that you're going to offer
digital dollars well let me help you
George
when uh we move money from your account
to my account
and you don't use actual physical
dollars to go to the branch and make a
deposit you have by definition moved
digital dollars baby
that's what they are yeah most
transactions in today's world are
digital like 98 are digital there's no
cash transactions they're not actually
shipping boatloads of Hard Cash there's
no other Banks there's a whole lot more
money in our economy with digital
transfers
flowing around currency it has a current
than uh than cash and they're not
talking about doing away with cash in
this proposal nothing I've read anywhere
except maybe some you know dark web
conspiracy theories say they're trying
to do away with cash now the downside is
if they actually issue a template which
is what they're talking about doing a uh
it's almost a crypto of sorts of the
dollar is what it amounts to they're
going to issue you a digital transaction
that's different than the digital
transactions that we do now
the downside is the fear is that they'll
start controlling those
digital doses that's the worry exactly
like ESG for instance they're gonna like
try to say okay if you're uh not gonna
be woke you're not going to be able to
use your digital dollars or if we wanted
to ration gasoline you're not going to
be able to use your digital dollars but
you can only use 50 digital dollars to
buy gas and then you have to come up
with other dollars of your own Black
Market dollars no it's not how it works
okay but that's that's the fear that's
out there DeSantis and Kennedy both came
out against this on the basis that the
Central Bank could overreach their use
of this as control and if they try to
use it for ESG stuff I would agree if
they're trying to control
currency and trying to invoke some kind
of power over it I I think that would be
a problem but I won't have all of my
money in their digital dollars I'll just
have it in digits in my account and
they're not going to force people to use
these digital dollars they couldn't
they it's the the conversion to that
would require a complete overall of
overhaul of the way we do everything in
our economy I mean think about it yeah
if you went from
have let's say you had to have a
certified number
to move money to venmo or to just to
reach over and move money from your
savings into your checking so you could
cover your Pizza Hut bill right or
whatever it is that this would be the
number of transactions this would
involve would be so large that for
government to get their arms around it
and control it I don't think it would be
possible on scale
I mean it would have to be some kind of
real fascism which honestly some of the
ESG stuff approaches fascism at times
because they've got this this they're
assigning values to their money they're
like religious zealots in a sense uh to
push their agendas and they'll stop at
nothing to do that but uh and that's of
course DeSantis and Kennedy's argument
is to keep the Central Bank not their
job to invoke social change
their job is to run the banking system
you stay in your lane let them stand and
as long as they do that no harm no foul
with any of this
now to the extent that they might do
that with the digital dollars it could
become it could become Harry and you
know uh it's a whole new place you could
get canceled
if you didn't meet the oh there'd be if
you didn't make the woke criteria or
whatever right and so you that that
would be a problem if your dollars
freaking got canceled that's a whole
different thing so uh if that got to
that point then I think long before then
we would have fired a bunch of people
and
um Americans just don't tolerate being
controlled for very long
with rare exceptions we're stubborn like
that with rare exceptions sometimes
we're sheeple and we all go into our
houses for 90 days and wait on a virus
to pass but other than that we very
seldom are controlled
most of the time we don't do what we're
told
and so which is good even if you
disagree with me you shouldn't have to
do what you're told that's called like
freedom and stuff so anyway that's the
downside of this thing that everybody's
moaning about but the implications are
you know I'm not losing sleep over this
I'm not going to bed worried at night
about what if centralized Banking and
digital dollars and cashless Society
this usually turns into fear-mongering
from the media and paranoia here's the
word here's a weird thing the faster you
can transfer funds
the more freedom you have
the more robust an economy is the more
freedom you have
the easier you can do a transaction the
more transactions occur the more
Prosperity you can endure uh and the
more freedom you have so the the first
part of this discussion this ease of
transfer and the shortening of the the
hold periods and all that because
they're updating the Antiquated system
is going to add way more freedoms than
the little corner of the digital dollars
might try to take away
so the net net on it I think is going to
be extremely positive although I'm not a
big fan of the fed and I'm not a
defender of the fed I'm certainly for
you bozos on Twitter not a shill of the
FED just to let you know but um matter
of fact I think some of the stuff
they're doing with interest rates are
some of the most asinine anti-economic
anti-capitalism stuff I've ever seen in
my life right now complete freaking
morons so there's the other side of the
equation if you were confused yeah now
he's been clear yeah but that's it I
mean you know so I overall this is good
overall this is good it's uh I I think
it's going to help and here here's an
interesting thing we can kind of parlay
into this too
I think what I said a few minutes ago
might be the most important part of our
little discussion on this I think
it's not the individual pieces of this
fed now thing the thing you need to
remember is
where there is no prosperity
where there is Extreme poverty
where the economics or economics are
hard to create where it's hard to start
and run a business where it's hard to
transact where everything's clamped down
where there's poverty
poverty follows a lack of Economic
Opportunity not the other way around
poverty is the result of uh economies
that are choked down where Freedom Is
Not So if you want more if you want less
poverty
statistically and historically if you'll
study the economies of the world if you
want less poverty increase Freedom
increased ease of transactions
increase ease of starting and release
less regulation on a business let people
go and do what people do Jefferson said
capitalism is what happens when you
leave people alone amen and that that
when you do that people nations rise up
out of poverty why do you think the
poverty level in the U.S is so much
lower than it is in developing countries
Freedom that's why Freedom matters
economically this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today his
brand new YouTube channel dropped today
check it out it is snark on steroids
you're gonna love it George Campbell
with a K on YouTube be sure you look it
up give him a follow so George the head
shot we're using there looks almost like
you've got highlights in your hair that
you don't have I look like a backstreet
boy it's all that airbrushing they do in
Photoshop to make me look human again is
that yeah maybe that's what it is
somebody got out of control there and
creative now we know what it would look
like if I got highlights so I'm going to
avoid this I mean you say it right there
right yeah it might be our screen I
don't know yeah I think it's the way
that's the lighting glancing off of all
your hair product is what it is that's
what it's the problems I don't have you
don't have to worry about Pomade
glistening no I get glistening but it's
a different kind it's just a general
bulb shine just a rawhide just a bulb
shine yeah that's it so hey if you're a
new listener and we know there's a bunch
of you based on our rankings and ratings
that are continually going up this year
thank you we appreciate that if you're
trying to learn the new lingo around
Ramsey like baby steps and debt
snowballs and such I will help you for
free go to
ramsaysolutions.com you can learn a lot
of stuff there but one thing you could
do is you could click the get started
button
get started and we'll help you figure
out the next best step for your
financial Journey exactly where you are
and what you do next and why and we'll
teach you all the whys because we don't
want you doing it because we said do it
we want you to do it because you
understand it and you think it's smart
because of course it is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Byron or Brian I'm sorry is with us
Brynn is with us I'll get it right in a
minute in Springfield Hey Bren what's up
hi I just wanted your advice on if you
think that we should pay off we have a
house that has a mortgage on it but we
have renters in it right now so I was
wondering if you think we should pay it
off or sell it
okay do you have a personal residence
this thing is provided here and so as
long as we stay here we have a house and
then when this ramp sells or the owner
passes away the house that we live in is
ours free and clear the ranch house
all right and so the only debt you have
in your whole life is this rental
yep we did Financial Peace University
when we were 23 and paid off 38 000.
four years so what part of Financial
Peace University did you miss where you
pay off the rental
um
yeah it's been a minute
so what is this rental cash flowing are
you guys wanting to keep it long term
um I think it'd be yeah like as I don't
know if it's a good investment since we
have a loan on it or not but so our
mortgage is like 18 19 on it and we rent
it out for 2200. that feels like real
tight
do you have the money to pay it off
today you have money to put on it no no
we don't have money to pay to pay it off
okay so you would pay it off what is the
question then whether you would pay it
off gradually or whether you would just
give up in salad
yeah okay how much do you owe on it
we owe 340. and uh what's your household
income
65 000 a year sell it
sell it yep you don't have enough margin
in this okay you said 2200 rent over an
eighteen hundred dollar payment if you
spit you're in a negative and you don't
have the income to cover negatives
one three thousand dollar heating and
air unit and you're in the negative
one leaking roof one month to two months
of not being paid and you're in the net
because it's empty or because they just
decide they're not going to pay you
because they don't like you or there's a
pandemic or whatever and you're in the
negative you have no margin here
right this thing's rubbing up and you
don't have the if you told me you made
265 you could absorb the blow of not of
not you know being able to make these
payments but if you start having to make
these payments out of your income that's
going to be really unfun
right get rid of it it's not an asset
it's a liability
then what do we do with the cash how
much cash are we talking so you have 340
owed what could you sell it for
after fees you're probably talking 50 or
60k you'd net yeah yeah and you don't do
you need the money for anything right
now
no okay I just invested in mutual funds
okay yeah just something simple just
keep it real simple but I I'm just
scared for you I'm afraid this is going
to end up being more of a curse than a
blessing matter of fact I'm pretty sure
it is over time
because
um
and George not not reflecting on her but
just in general this is the problem
we've talked about this before that over
uh ever so many years uh the get rich
quick real estate movement kicks up
again it's about a seven or eight year
cycle roughly
um because you have to get the young
people who don't remember how stupid it
was a little bit older so they start
doing stupid stuff and so that that's
what you know there's a whole movement
when I was when I was a Wee child
the get rich quick real estate movement
was some goober on midnight cable
television selling get rich tapes
sitting by the ocean you too could sit
by the ocean and hear the waves if you
were yeah and they got rich but most of
us went broke the guy's selling the
tapes got rich but most of us that did
their stuff went broke and then it came
another cycle came through and then the
latest of course is the Tic Tac goobers
in skinny jeans telling people to buy
nothing down real estate and the the
classic line from that Bunch whether it
was 40 years ago or whether it's 40
minutes ago is the renters will pay this
off for you
proof you have never if people this if
you say that that tells me one thing
passive income day I've owned over 2 000
pieces of real estate in my life I've
got a whole I've got several hundred
million dollars worth of real estate
today okay one thing I know for sure is
if you tell me the renters are going to
pay the payments for you that tells me
you've never managed rental property
that tells me you've never done it
that's a hundred percent you are a
novice at best an idiot at worst and um
I mean that's the truth because
anybody who's ever had a renter and or
been a renter and I have both I've been
a renter too it knows that sometimes
renters don't pay
sometimes there's cancer
sometimes there's car wrecks and job
loss sometimes there's a pandemic
sometimes dot dot dot dot dot
it's you know as if there's a perfect
stream of every month the rent is going
to come on time or early and you can pay
your stupid little payment
and that's the most ridiculous
assumption
which indicates a lack of experience or
knowledge of how rental property really
works well they get Starry Eyed by the
numbers and they turn their risk meter
off and just go it'll all work out as
long as it works out until it doesn't
work out yeah and if you want to go
broke don't just turn off your estimator
do what I did in my 20s take a hammer to
it just smash smash that sucker and
because I had absolutely no perception
of risk I was 100 sure I could out earn
my stupidity
and stupidity will chase you down and
run you over like last week's cat in the
road I mean really it's bad it'll get
you well and you learned this the hard
way but now your advice of paying cash
for investment property feels even more
counter-cultural and controversial than
it was back in the day yeah and one of
the beauties of doing what I did which
is go broke one of the beauties of going
broke is you no longer care what people
think
I am not trying to impress a 26 year old
on Tic Tac I can that you're the last
person I care what they think I'm not
mad at you but you're supposed to take
my advice not the other way around I'm
really not interested in your input much
less do I even care so uh it's just real
I'm not you know I know what I'm doing
and I know what's worked over 40 years
and I know how much wealth has been
built because I don't have any risk I
mean virtually no risk rental properties
we had all kinds of people we had all
this commercial property
um you know we had one that was like a
crossfit type gym a burn thing or
whatever they call it right well guess
what guess what they did during the
pandemic shutdown nothing you know guess
what the daycare did in one of our
properties nothing oh you want me to
keep going how about the dance studio
for the kitties nothing you know guess
how much rent they could pay because
they had nothing coming in this is how
life works and guess how much the
lenders cared there weren't any there
were no lenders oh my god there were no
lenders
so I could have all kinds of mercy be
helpful be understanding be demanding I
could do whatever I wanted to do it's a
different position this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
George camel Ramsey personality co-host
of the smart money happy hour with
Rachel Cruz our very popular podcast and
YouTube show launches today his own
YouTube channel George camel with a k k
camel look at it
k-a-m-e-l in other words check it out on
YouTube
um he has the gift of snark which makes
him one of my favorite people on YouTube
right now
it's a spiritual thing it's a spiritual
gift it's it's inside what's yours Dave
it's in second hesitations cynicism
there we go there you go all right I got
that one down all right Ross
not really Ross is in Montgomery Alabama
hey Ross what's up
hey
um but y'all thank you for taking my
call
um I so I have a um traditional IRA that
I put around 260 a month in and then I
saved 500 a month
um and
I'm running right now and I really want
to buy a house and possibly get my
roommates to pay my mortgage
um so yeah I'm just wondering what
should I do
so what you're talking about is kind of
a house hacking thing where you want to
get in the house but they you charge
them rent it covers the mortgage and
more and this is like passive income
right in the house on
um renting in right now uh it's there I
know the landowner pretty good and he is
willing to sell it to me but I don't
know how much he wants for it yet do you
have any money
uh I have around 7
000 saved up
what do you make a year
uh around just got right so around 32.
how old I'm 10.99. I'm 23. okay all
right
um okay you're not quite ready to buy a
house
okay houses are a blessing
if you have the wiggle room in your life
for them to sit there and go up in value
they are a curse if they uh if they make
You Broker
that's why we call them Brokers you get
broker and broker when you buy a house
and you're not ready so you need an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
set aside probably your seven thousands
pretty close to that
okay okay and then you need to save up a
good down payment
above that and
um and then you need to be able to pay
the payment if none of your roommates
pay you right
because that could happen
right yeah
that's exactly right yeah and um
sometimes it does happen so yeah that's
the uh you know and it sounds to me like
that um
that you the idea of owning a house is
bigger deal to you than the actual fact
that you've kind of heard oh buying a
house is a good idea which it is by the
way but buying a house when you're broke
will make you it will hurt you rather
than help you especially when your
tenants are your friends and they live
in the same house that's a dangerous
situation too because if it's your buddy
dude I can't pay you this month man I'll
get you next month I promise and all of
a sudden it turns into three months and
he hasn't paid and now you have to evict
your friend and so you've destroyed a
relationship yeah and
sometimes
when you're particularly in your early
20s your tenants not only your friend
they're your drinking buddy
you really can't trade
a case of Corona for rent it won't work
have you tried so I I might have known a
guy
um one time that did something like that
so I don't know it's possible but the uh
no that that's it's a problem
so uh you know I I would get yourself on
a much more solid ground financially so
that the home becomes a blessing and
doesn't pinch you
uh where you have very little money very
little income and
[Music]
um
and then the roommates don't pay
and like you said then you've got to
evict your friends or your drinking
buddies or whatever all this stuff it's
a problem Jordan's in Traverse City
Michigan hey Jordan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
okay Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so recently discovered you and your baby
steps love it and I'm completely on
board with the baby steps so
fast forward to my current situation my
family and I are relocating for my job
moving to a new city we're going to buy
a new house there
we are selling our current house we
stand to walk away from that deal with
about a hundred thousand dollars cash
that we're going to put towards the new
house
haven't it wiped out all of our debt yet
I have
about 12 000 left on my truck that I
could very easily pay off and then our
lease on another car is ending soon and
we either keep it or let it go so it
could very easily wipe out all of our
debt my question is is how much of our
savings do we use
to put towards a down payment of our new
house to keep our payment at 25
of our monthly income like you recommend
on a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
so let me get this straight you take
this 100 you pay off all of your debt
plus set aside a three to six month
emergency fund whatever's left you would
use as a down payment
houses to be completely used as a down
payment
uh currently we have about 92
000 in savings okay and another another
interesting fact is my wife is Canadian
she has
sixty thousand dollars Canadian sitting
there which is about 44 000 US dollars
which would after conversion would be
about forty four thousand so in total
let's just be real close possibly 136
000. yeah you're not doing the baby
steps you just got introduced to them
but you're not doing them yet
uh because the baby steps would have
entailed paying off all of your debt
except your house as soon as you
understood them because you have the
money to do that
you have 92 plus 100 plus 42 right
uh correct
okay so I mean we're dealing with Dad
Gum over two hundred thousand dollars
minus paying off your debt
minus uh an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and the rest is
your down payment and yes you would buy
a house then where the payment is no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
what's how expensive is the house you're
selling
uh we sold it for two hundred and
fifteen thousand and where are you
moving to
called Sault Ste Marie oh fabulous great
town
very similar uh maybe even cheaper
housing prices than Traverse City agreed
uh yes agreed much cheaper yeah Traverse
City's got a bit of the Resort pricing
going on and Susan probably doesn't have
that trouble yeah so you can buy
Morehouse and put down all you've got
except the emergency fund and your
debt-free cars now
so you either buy out the lease or sell
the car and buy a car uh you pay off the
other car you put an emergency fund of
three to six months aside and you've
easily got 150 Plus
to put towards your house then you
almost are going to pay for it correct
you almost pay for it yeah because I
yeah I need 150 to put towards the new
house to keep that 15-year mortgage at
25 of my monthly income okay let me make
sure I didn't miss something then
because the numbers are pretty obvious
in front of me right now 12 on a car
plus a lease it's got to go away and you
got to buy a car so I'm going to call
that another twelve thousand dollars
thirteen thousand dollars that's 25 000
bucks
and you got cars okay
go buy a 15 000 car pay off your twelve
thousand dollar car turn in the lease
okay that puts us at 25 Grand
you with me
uh yes yeah 12 and 13 is 25.
uh well I I have 12 000 on my truck that
I'm gonna pay off that's what I said
like like now yep so I said and that's
the new number that's the only debt you
have other than your house did I get
that right
correct okay and you've got 92 in the
bank
and you've got 100 coming out of your
house that's 192. and we've got the
Canadian 60 that turns into 40.
44 yes okay
so all of those three numbers add up to
over 200 minus 25 puts it about 200. and
minus your emergency fund you don't have
a fifty thousand dollar emergency fund
so sorry so you're putting down 150 and
you're 100 debt free with an emergency
fund in place other than your house and
if you buy a 200 000 something thousand
dollar house let's get the thing paid
off really really fast you're in great
shape man
the plan only works if you're working
and it's real simple but it's hard
because you have to decide
that works man yeah but the numbers are
iron clad there on that one they're just
right in front of you this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
all right
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George Campbell
Ramsey personality and my co-host today
is my co-host today the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we have announced today that George
camel now has his own YouTube channel
check him out at George camel with a K
George c k a m e l not C and you can
find him at YouTube and uh the snark
will be delivered the uh taking down of
bad financial products and mythology
will be delivered and George is
excellent at that and we're excited that
this is a new offering from the Ramsey
networks there on YouTube George is also
the co-host of the smart money happy
hour which with Rachel Cruz which is
wildly popular congratulations George
thank you big day it's like you know we
deliver the baby and here it is and you
don't want anyone to call your baby ugly
this is true but they will just be ready
oh they are it's called YouTube comments
we love it hey we're going to start this
hour with Ashley in Jacksonville Florida
hi Ashley how are you thank you
hi I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so I wanted to talk through an issue my
husband he recently purchased I guess
it's been about a year he purchased a 72
000 car
um and we are not in a financial place
to have been able to afford that car
he's currently the only one working and
as of now I believe we still owe 62
000 on the car and obviously that's not
including interest
um so our finances kind of look at the
moment he's paying 1200 a month for the
car
um not including insurance I know
um and then for rent we pay about
fifteen hundred
so there's been like a very big struggle
obviously between trying to keep up with
that and then saving and trying to just
kind of invest in our future so
obviously horrible horrible decision but
I'm hoping there's a way that we can
kind of get back from the
did he do this without telling you
um we actually just got married last
year and I believe it's kind of a
terrible story I'm not even gonna say
it's a funny story it's not he had a car
that he just completely paid off
so he had that car perfectly good
condition and then he decided he wanted
to get an SUV which he purchased for
about 32 000 I think and then the
dealership emailed him saying hey we
have a great deal for you you can bring
that new car and trade it in and upgrade
to this electric car that he's been
wanting so he did not he briefly
mentioned that to me and from what he
told me it sounded like it was kind of
going to be an equal trade maybe he'd be
paying a little bit more that's what it
sounded like to me so he went did that
took care of it and then it wasn't until
a few months ago that I fully understand
like the gravity of what had actually
happened but all of that occurred before
you were married
um like during during the time like
before I mean he didn't he did not do
this while you were at the altar so
there is no during
yeah it was before or after you were
married you were legally married and
then he did this
okay yeah and then of course when I
questioned them about like what was
possibly going through his mind he
honestly didn't really have an
explanation and just said it was an
extremely stupid decision that he just
couldn't
um take back and now we found something
we agree on okay yeah but why can't he
just go sell this car today what do you
mean you can't take it back so the
reason why he's not able to sell it is
because the highest amount he's even
getting for this car now is forty
thousand dollars and we still owe like
65 or sixty three thousand dollars who
said
um he's talked to a few dealerships
about this yeah he's not good at this
yeah we're talking private party here of
course if you go to a dealership
who made who's the maker
Kia it's like an electric Kia seventy
two thousand dollars for a Kia yeah I
know I know
not not okay he paid 72 000 for it when
um this was in
April of 2022
and you're telling me one year
and it dropped in half 32 000 drops no
no I'm not buying it he's justifying why
you should keep this call a lot of talk
okay because I'm just I think I'm
calling BS this is a guy don't want to
sell the car
and he's trying to make this deal out
worse than this but let's just pretend
it's 50 and not 40 which it could be
okay all right we still got a uh a
twelve thousand dollar hole right and
what does he make
um about 90. okay
and do you have any other debt
um no major deaths just a couple uh
smaller dots on credit cards under under
two thousand dollars
okay that's your only debt other than
your home do you own a home
no we don't we're renting good okay so
he makes 90. he owes 65 on a car 62. 62
on a car and when let's pretend you can
sell it for 50. okay
um and uh uh uh it's a key of what
What car what
ev6 EVC they're running from as low as
46 but it quickly goes up to 50 plus so
you could definitely sell this thing for
50 plus so I think your husband called
the same dealer the screwed him the
first time and asked them what did they
give him for it and they thought oh
we're gonna get this guy again the third
time we're going to screw this guy over
yeah so 40 is below wholesale
so if you put the thing on the market on
trader.com or such something like that
and sold it yourself
uh the market value private sale is
closer is in the 50s like I suspected
okay because the numbers you were giving
us were just unbelievable that the car
would pay even a Kia would lose that
much in one year it's just unbelievable
so all right so he's not good at this or
he doesn't want to sell it one the two
or both so we're going to sell it for 50
and we're going to borrow 12 to cover
the difference
from your local bank or your credit
union
and you probably need to borrow about
you don't have do you have any money
um not much saved up that's not much
um like
four to five thousand dollars good okay
so I would borrow I would borrow 10 and
buy a five thousand dollar car
and borrow 10 and be ten thousand
dollars in debt and we'll call that debt
stupid tax
yeah which is what I have to pay when I
do something stupid
okay and you guys have a rule from this
point forward in your marriage we do not
make financial decisions without both of
us being involved and being in agreement
oh yeah I made that very very clear no
you didn't because he did this after you
were married
I know well now I made it very Ashley
from today forward you are involved with
the money in this marriage yeah you were
a part of there's no more I didn't know
and he is too and he is too you know so
um yeah both of you have a vote and both
of you decide but what I would do is I
would borrow ten thousand dollars I
would buy a five thousand dollar card
for cash and I would sell this car and
then I would pay off the ten thousand
dollars with your 90 income and no
payments if no payments but the ten
thousand dollars and your couple of low
credit cards that you need to cut up
today
and uh we're gonna help you because you
guys are getting started on a rough foot
here on a sore foot from kicking each
other and um we're gonna put you into
Financial Peace University I'll pay for
it if you will both promise to go when
you talk to Austin you're on hold with
him right now
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
listen up everybody our smart conference
weekend is here in Nashville it's
happening this weekend tickets have been
going fast and there's a just a couple
like 15 or 20 left and you can get yours
today join me in all the Ramsay
personalities Rachel Cruz Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman George Campbell and
Jade warshaw April 14th and 15th Friday
and Saturday Friday evening and all day
Saturday to help us make Ramsay history
with this first ever event in the brand
new Ramsey Event Center you're going to
leave energized equipped and smarter in
every area of your life like money
career relationships mental health all
of that and since it's the first time in
the new event center you're going to get
the commemorative badge with your ticket
plus you'll have a chance to meet us all
the Ramsey personalities and on top of
that I hear there might even be some
music this is Nashville after all Dave's
going to pull the guitar out finally no
America's been waiting no I'm in talk
radio for a reason I play the radio
You've Got Talented friends I have lots
of talented friends and I know my Lane
he knows a guy so there you go hey
tickets start at only 119 they uh
literally I think they're 17 or 18
tickets left so thanks for coming
everybody we're excited for this also
since it is basically a sellout uh let's
talk about this this is important uh
we're gonna do a live stream George a
free live stream for those of you that
can't be there in person we're going to
be broadcasting all of the money talks
from the morning including Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz myself you're going to hear
from all three of us for free that's
incredible Saturday morning the first
three talks at the day-long uh you're
gonna miss the Friday night event but
you can we're gonna stream the morning
oh and we're charging a lot
it's I mean it's a full two days I mean
we're charging a lot for this live
stream in the morning oh completely that
one would be free it's got zeros on the
end zero point zero zero zero zero zero
yeah lots of zeros it's not gonna we're
gonna try it's free live stream the
first three talks in the morning from
Smart conference from the brand new
Ramsey Event Center you can tune in get
a feel for everything that's going on
and uh you get it'll help you get a
little fomo and you won't want to miss
the next one that way right and uh but
hey sign up for free because we
mentioned it's free Georgia's talk
Rachel's talking my talk on this coming
Saturday morning live that's why they
call it a live stream be the only time
it's available by the way uh
ramseysolutions.com
live and you can sign up for free for
the free live stream Margaret's in
Huntsville hey Margaret welcome to the
Ramsay show
thanks for having me how are you today
better than we deserve what's up
I'm calling because I am I'm new to
health insurance as a newer to being on
my own plan
I had to have some unexpected expenses
come up in the past few months and in
October I have CT scan and then in
December ended up having to have a
surgery to remove what they found from
that PT scan WOW and my question for you
today is is there and I'm by the way I'm
100 healthy now I'm very blessed and
fortunate
um my question for you is is that I just
got off the phone with my health care
provider and was finding out that I owe
about 4 500 from the CT scan and the
surgery combined and that's after the 80
20 split and I thought baby 20 sport
would be applied afterwards because with
my surgery I hit the deductible for the
year
um so my question to you guys is how do
you recommend I find a way to pay for
this like by negotiating maybe to get a
lower rate I believe I've heard before
maybe you can offer to pay in cash and
negotiate but I just didn't know what to
do so I thought I would call you guys
so this was a fifty thousand dollar
surgery
yes sir it was fifty one thousand
dollars
okay wow
um well I'm glad you're okay
um that's a scary thing to go through
and it sounds like you've got reasonably
good insurance in place
um with a deductible plus uh an 80 20.
so the 45 you had already met the
deductible before this happens with
other things
no sir so my plan starts on October 1st
so all this stuff started happening so
by so from what I understand by the time
um the plan was contracted it was the
difference was six thousand dollars and
then they had to apply the 3 800
deductible that I had not met yet
and then when they subtracted the six
thousand from the 3800 they got with the
plan paid so then they did 20 of that
and added it to the deductible I have
not paid yet and that's how I got to
forty three hundred dollars and then
that additional money to get to the 45
was the cost of the CT scan that I had
before so your total bills right now
that you have to pay is forty five
hundred dollars
yes and then I already had some stuff
this year and it was a 500 deductible
for the secondary so in total from the
past few months five thousand seventy
five dollars and fifty Seven but you've
already paid that or you still have 5
000 outstanding
what do you mean 4 500 or the 4300
rather is what I'm more concerned about
I'm sorry what did you say what do you
make
I make a little over 60. how much money
how much money emergency fund how much
um a ten thousand dollar emergency fund
okay
um and I and so I follow you religiously
as much as I can so I'm very blessed I
have enough cash to be able to pay this
in full but I just wanted to find a way
maybe I could negotiate it a little bit
later and I just really don't know how I
would just call them
and say um
um how old are you
I'm less than 28. okay are you single
I'm recently married okay I'm a 28 year
old Newlywed I've never been in this
situation before
um
and this is you calling and talking to
them okay and um this is all really
scary for me if I pay you cash how much
of a discount can you give me if I pay
it right now
and whatever they say whatever they say
ask them to send an email verifying that
amount and then send them the money that
day
and put it behind you if it's if it's
full prices
that's fine it doesn't matter if you
have even out of your checking account
it's not adversary bring a check to the
billing department whatever you want to
do whatever you need to do
okay and then the other thing was
someone told me to make sure it didn't
credit bureau it won't is that a thing
no not if they not if they decide to
accept lest
because they haven't turned it over to
your to a collections yet
if you settle it if you call them up and
say I owe you you know a particular
vendor okay let's say you owe them two
thousand dollars I owe you two thousand
dollars what will you accept and they
say 1500 you say okay thank you so much
I'll send it to you today
but I need an email verifying that that
is paid in full and then I'll send it to
you today and then they can have the
billing send that right out to you and
then you can pay it right then and there
will be no collections there'll be no no
not no dings on your credit because
there's no reason for them to turn into
credit they just negotiated the bill
it's a negotiated price just like if you
go in the dress store and the dress is
on sale for 200 and you say uh would you
take less and they say yes 150 they
don't turn that in on your credit
yes sir it's the same thing have you
asked for an itemized bill
um yes and I have it okay and the amount
matched up
but I just want you to verify because
sometimes they'll throw things in there
when you ask for an itemized bill they
go oh maybe we should took off take off
that Advil we charge 75 for and so you
can get a discount that way just by
getting them to own up and go let's
actually show them what we charged but
if the you got the itemized bill and
it's 4500 I think the cash offer is the
way to go yeah and and I'm I'm not
expecting a big discount by the way in
this situation
what would you think it could be I have
no idea but I would I mean if they knock
off 10 or 20 percent I think you had a
good day
yes sir I would agree and either way
just just pay it one more question sure
yes I'll pay it um so my husband's
Insurance
um we're trying to figure out if we
should just stay separate or go with or
just pay the extra to go on his
um the way his plan is is that if the
spouse has an insured portion from their
work they'd have to add a hundred
dollars a month
yeah I mean if you're getting yours for
free no I wouldn't unless it's far
superior coverage I'd have to look at
the coverage but I doubt it if there's
similar coverages I wouldn't I wouldn't
pay extra to be on his plan when you got
yours no benefit there
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
watching guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Jason and Jody are with us hey
guys how are you good how are you Dave
better than we deserve where do you guys
live Jacksonville Florida oh welcome to
Nashville good to have you all right and
uh how much debt have you guys paid off
a total of uh 365
000. wow how long did this take about
seven years and ten months all right and
your range of income during that seven
years and 10 months so we started out at
about 80 a little under 80 and we're now
about 175. excellent what do you guys do
for a living so I am a Wireless
Communications engineer and
I do adoptions from Foster Care
excellent wow very cool okay 365 000 was
what kind of debt uh so um 86 000 was
consumer and the rest of it was actually
the house you paid off your home
what's this house worth uh so right now
it's close to about 400. way to go very
cool and how much do you guys have in
your retirement accounts
probably about 160 between the two of us
way to go you're heading towards
millionaire halfway there way to go
congratulations how's it feel to have
your house paid off wonderful it's
amazing it's just there's so much you
can do now we can do now without a
payment amen amen so what started you on
this journey seven years and ten months
ago it actually started earlier than
that my sister she's seven years older
than me and I I just graduated college
and was unemployed looking for a job and
I was babysitting her twin twin boys my
nephews and she had your book on on her
coffee table wasn't using it um so I
read it and
I thought well I mean I don't have any
money coming in so I of course made
every excuse and put it back down and
then we had our first son and both of us
were kind of like we need to do
something to change this and a couple of
my friends at work were also doing or
we're doing Financial Peace University
at their church and so that's how we got
connected ah okay so you went to
Financial Peace we didn't actually go
through I just listened to your podcast
all the way through
um I still listen to it when we were in
here it was the Baker Street was playing
and my son is that why we're here wow
this is why we listen to this every
every day he's been hearing that since
before he was born I like it very cool
all right so Jason how did she get you
fired up about this you know I kind of
just followed along and I I saw things
you know snowballing and this is this is
really working I I think I'll jump on
board too yeah engineer mindset you're
like all right this is a process it
works I'm on board yes I have to I have
to see facts yeah absolutely I don't
blame you me too well done you guys well
done that's a long slog but you got the
house and everything done seven years
that's about the average people paying
off their house in about seven years
yeah wow did you pre-decide you were
going to pay off the house at the end of
the Consumer Debt what made you just
keep going
we did I mean it was we just didn't like
being in debt and once you saw those
numbers go down it's like we can do the
rest of it no problem yeah we reach over
and knock it out yeah it's fun because
you're definitely not normal anymore I
love it so when someone says how did you
get out of debt how'd you pay off your
house at this young age what do you tell
them well you know you tell
you everybody says that you know you
have to be on the same page you have to
support everybody but what really said
it um really got it going for us was
that when I got that new job we
continued to live off of the original
salaries that we were making but that
extra money all went to debt and I tell
you it really got that snowball going
really fast for us yeah live on less
than you make avoid lifestyle creep
that's what they call it you get a raise
and you just spend it you don't know
where it went but you guys went no we're
going to keep living on less so we have
more margin to pay off this debt that's
it we also I had um my grandparents
lived in Central Florida for 60 years in
the same house without any central air
conditioning whoa and I always reminded
myself and Jason when we were going
through things and we're trying to
figure out if we should buy this or not
I was always thinking deciphering want
versus need and so if my grandparents at
80 years old can stay in a house with no
Central hair and eating in Florida in
Florida yeah
um we can we can live without the air
conditioning in our car right now
and then you get there and now you can
do anything you want to do yep so what's
your first big thing to do now that you
don't know a stinking dime in the world
to anybody
well we did a Disney trip with one of
our close friends and her girls
um and that was exciting
um and expensive yes it is Disney's
Proud of their services
and then being here we took our plight
First Flight as a family of five which
was a big deal yeah it is yeah so
probably a good little Southwest jump
from uh Jacksonville to Nashville you
got it yeah I've done that one myself a
time or two Excellence they went from
Disneyland to Ramsey Solutions which
one's better
yeah this one's free yeah we're not
gonna charge you for the ride I'm just
saying yeah and the cookies are free so
it's quite the opposite it's a Disney
inverse relationship oh my gosh the way
to go you guys so proud of you
congratulations who was cheering you on
from the outside
so we had friends and um my mom his
parents my sister my really good friend
Robin Staley and her late husband Tim
were big fans and went through this
journey with us yeah way to go very cool
you guys congratulations very cool we've
got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you The Total
Money Makeover book and Financial Peace
membership for you to either go through
it now or give it to somebody now that
you're here baby steps millionaire is
definitely your next step in your
situation you're on your way that's
called the live and give bundle the live
and give box and so we'll give that to
you at the break here and let's bring
the guys up and introduce them hot with
their names and ages so we got we got
Vincent we got Victor and we got Henry
and three almost six and nine all right
ready to go ready to go look at those
good guys I'm matching blue polos yeah I
didn't have anything to do with that by
the way
well their family tree has been their
lives have been changed and they don't
even completely understand what you two
have done for them but you're in really
really good shape congratulations well
done
and then Jody Henry Victor and Vincent
Jacksonville Florida
365 house and everything paid off seven
years and ten months making 80 to 175
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream ready guys three two one
[Applause]
well done you guys that's what it's
about just steadily plowing through
right there now a whole nother life
completely changed so
George that means that we've now done 53
debt-free screams this year Wow since
the beginning of the year for a total of
just under 10 million dollars
in debt paid off total that's pretty
incredible
so all kinds of backgrounds all kinds of
incomes
all kinds of family situations
everybody's doing it and you've done
this for 30 years now
and the best part is that's encouraging
to me is that anyone at any point can
just decide I mean that's just that's
like a magic trick that you could just
wake up and go I don't want to live with
360 000 worth of debt anymore I want
things to be different and then you just
slowly but surely follow a proven
process and pay it off yep you get after
it there's no magic to it you got a
secret service you got to get after it
you got to push it through you can do
this and what we know is that um we are
positive because we personally witnessed
people from every background every
income every situation every race Creed
and color uh have been able to do this
stuff and we're willing to help all of
you we want to help all of you because
it's why we're here it is so fun to sit
here and hear your stories of winning
with a whole new look on Mental Health a
whole new look on your career a whole
new look on your money
man it's a completely different
situation than most people live this is
fun stuff it's called the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today announcing today that
Ramsey networks has launched a brand new
YouTube show on the George camel with a
K George camel
YouTube channel you want to check it out
it's pretty incredible exposing the
system that's designed to keep you broke
you're going to get into all of it
aren't you George everything you can
imagine all the traps all of the trends
I'm going to break the complex down into
simple make the boring stuff fun to
hopefully give you guys some hope and
tell you the truth about money and help
you win good stuff check it out George
Campbell on YouTube brand new show uh
dropped today he's the co-host on the
ever popular smart money happy hour with
Rachel Cruz as well hey folks if you're
liking what you're hearing here we
appreciate you we do not have a 300
million dollar marketing budget or any
football stadiums named after us
like uh
um so um nobody and we actually help
people as opposed to so far excuse me
get this guy some clarity Tennessee this
year
um but the uh yeah we
actually just help people and if you
want to help us since you're just kind
of chiming in here for free uh tell
people about this show tell us where
you're listening tell them you know send
a share off of the YouTube or share off
your podcast or just tell people let's
do it on such talk radio station or
watch on TBN whatever it is you're doing
to let people know that we're here share
it not number number two they should
leave a five-star review the others
aren't helpful no and I don't understand
why you would even take the time to go
to a podcast review just to be like I
didn't like just move on with your life
if you paid for it and then it was a bad
deal I might that's one thing but I mean
just move on anyway mama said if you
ain't anything nice to say don't say
anything at all so five star review
would be awesome share it would be
awesome subscribe hit the follow button
hit the Subscribe button all three of
those things Advance us forward in the
algorithms that these different
platforms use and cause people who don't
know this show exists so no it exists so
you're very helpful when you do all
three of those thank you very very much
Anna is in Chicago hi Anna welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um
so my husband and I are kind of in a
unique position we've been married for a
few years and the only doubt we've had
with student loans which we were working
really hard towards paying off and then
um you know with covid they end up
getting deferred but we still you know
took the same amount of money and just
put into savings
um and we why don't you pay them off
well I I know that's kind of a a touchy
topic with you my arm mentality is he's
been watching everything at the
government you know he's waiting to see
if the 10 Grand's forgiven
um how much do you owe
his are around 80k and mine are what the
hell's 10 grand got to do with it you
owe 80 grand
well it could be 10 grand less that we
give to them
so pay them off
all right how much have you got in the
bank
um we well we did have about 90k and so
um you know we we had reached the amount
that he had and he took he's like so
here's the thing Anna if you owe eighty
thousand dollars that you signed up for
and you have ninety thousand dollars to
pay it
you should pay it you owe the money
I don't want to have to pay it for you
I'm a taxpayer
that has to pay this
because you're trying to play some
freaking game with the government you
should just pay your bill that's what
you should do all right Stephen is with
us Stephen is in Washington D.C Hey
Stephen how are you
hey David good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so one of your inputs
um on a decision that my wife and I are
trying to make right now looking to
decide between whether or not we should
pay cash to build a small mother-in-law
Suite or take out a construction loan to
build the primary residence on a five
acre lot that we just purchased
I'm confused where's the Mother-in-law
Suite
on a house you currently own Swede
no we're currently renting right now
where would you add the Mother-in-law
Suite where would you add the
Mother-in-law Suite to a rental do you
build the Mother-in-law Suite first and
then build the main house as an addition
down the road
um once we have some more money saved up
oh it's not really for the mother-in-law
correct really for you so you're
basically building a tiny house for now
yes until you can afford the primary
yes
how much money do you have so we're
looking
so we'll have about 200 000 saved up and
by the end of the year which is when
we're looking to start construction
um
the Mother-in-law Suite that we're
thinking about we could build within
that budget and pay cash for the primary
house that would be option b
um we think would be around the seven
hundred thousand dollars to build so
we'd do a construction loan to fund
um that what do you guys make a year
what's your household income
um we're around 215 a year
okay
well there's two answers to the equation
are two answers to the question
um around here we don't yell at people
for taking out a mortgage that is more
than a fourth of your take as long as
the payments no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay on a 15-year
uh fixed rate and this construction loan
converted to a permanent mortgage after
completion of construction would not
violate that
so you'd be within the things that we
suggest here okay the second answer to
the equation is I don't borrow money
I pay cash for things or I don't do them
period and so that's always an option as
well which is the second which is the
thing so either way you go you would be
within the guidelines of what we
suggest here you're going to be easily
within those guidelines
um
so how long have you been saving money
about about five or so years
you've not been making this kind of
money that long then
no okay how long you been making 250.
um
combine uh we recently got married
So within the past six months or so yeah
we've been steadily increasing you know
what I what I would do is I would lay
out the game plan that says if I build
the whole house
how fast can I pay it off
okay okay so let's pretend that you put
two hundred thousand down and you got
the paid for lot already right
yes and you're making 250 and you borrow
750 and we put we agree we're going to
put 150 a year on it and so we're going
to be done in like five years or
something like that if you said that to
each other and you wanted to go ahead
and build the house so we're going to
pay off the whole thing in five years
and have a paid for house that by then
will probably be worth a million dollars
well with a lot in all it would be for
sure with the five acres
be probably worth that from day one but
the uh um or close
anyway all of that makes sense but
that's a way you could look at it and
say then what we're arguing about is not
really whether we take out a
construction loan and a permanent
mortgage what we're really arguing about
is five years
how long we wait to be debt free okay
we're arguing about do we have the house
for the five years and and pay it off
very aggressively or do we save up very
aggressively and build the house a
little bit at a time with the
Mother-in-law Suite strategy yeah and
you're basically pre-deciding before you
ever jump into this purchase what's
going to happen instead of hoping that
you can make the numbers work that's
always a bad plan so if you walk into
this with patience and you realize I
don't need the Mother-in-law Suite let's
just do the primary residence but we
wait a year that might be the other
option
yeah yeah so you're all of these in
other words fall within the smart column
none of these are in the dumb column
none of these are you're being
ridiculous or anything like that the key
is to keep on living like you were
making the money you were making before
yeah that'd be pretty cool yeah just
just kind of keep your lifestyle down
and you can chunk this thing away real
fast which sets you up to be sitting in
a million dollar property with a million
dollar net worth at a very young age
making 250 000 a year you're gonna be so
wealthy it'll be unbelievable with no
house payment that's going to be a
pretty cool place to be so regardless of
which way you get there that should be
where you are within five years or so
really cool well done very well done
Stephen this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the pods for moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where we
help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
thank you for joining us America open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five George camel the
co-host of smart money happy hour with
Rachel Cruz is my co-host today and
announcing uh this week a brand new
YouTube show the George Campbell show on
YouTube produced of course here by
Ramsey networks Joe exciting week for
you George incredible team
I'll take Joe Campbell that's a
different spin but this this is big I've
I've done a lot of things with the
Ramsay network with borrowed future fine
print Ramsay show smart money happy hour
but this one is truly me uh just the
purest form in all the snark all the pop
culture all the Deep Dives all of the
nerdery and I really just want to help
people understand the truth about money
and how to actually win because there's
a lot of myths and a lot of Hope
Stealers out there telling you the wrong
ways to do it and so so I just want to
swim upstream and try to help people do
it the right way because that's what
happened for me I went from negative net
worth to millionaire by following a
proven plan if you listen to the show
you know the plan and I just want to
show people it still works today even in
this economy Stacy's in Shreveport
Louisiana hi Stacy welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave thank you for taking
no problem never lost a patient how can
we help okay it's just a question that
my husband and I disagree on he's had an
American Express card since he was 18.
he's 52 now that's precious and he says
that he cannot shut that card down
because if he does it'll destroy his
credit and we don't use the card that
card we don't use any card at all now
but he hasn't used that card for many
many years but he still pays a 250
annual fee to keep the card
and right now I we're like turning no
more credit cards anymore at all I've
convinced him he he was a credit card
user I'm not and
um I'm saying that we shouldn't pay this
annual fee we just shouldn't have that
credit card at all and he just is in
total disagreement because he says his
credit Will tank if we do that
that's why I'm asking you he's still you
he doesn't use the card
so you're not borrowing any money
anywhere
ever
well we have debt oh
okay
let me help you an American Express card
that you don't use does not affect your
credit
it only affects your credit if you use
it
he says if he
keeps telling me this and
it's going to tank his credit he's wrong
okay he's mathematically wrong it's not
it's not a philosophy mechanically the
way the algorithm is used at FICO to
create a credit score it has to do with
activity if you have zero activity on
your accounts you don't have a credit
score
inspirational activity
and so it says so if he if he puts it in
the drawer and never gets it out and
pays 250 it's not helping nor hurting
his credit and one not one iota
it just does it's not how it works
I guess he said said that since you've
had it since he was 18. it doesn't
matter is it a pet or a card
it's largely emotional I remember
getting rid of my blankie when I turned
into an adult and he needs to do the
same that's all this is it's just a
blankie at this point and it's special
to him because it you walk with him
through all the seasons of life but it's
not the first person that told him he
was an adult
it was his first love
yeah well and he thinks that all of our
kids should get a credit card when they
turn 18 to get their credit going well
let's talk let's talk about that for a
second because that's I think that's the
core issue not whether you keep a stupid
American Express card for 250 and don't
use it which is irrelevant but so the
bottom line is he still believes that
being in debt is the best way to live
your life and to prosper
okay then no no
no because there's no other reason he
needs to be confronted on this because
there's no other reason to build your
credit
you don't need credit
unless you're going to borrow money
yeah and I think that we'll see we might
well we have a mortgage right now and he
works in Shreveport I actually live well
we live about an hour and a half away
but an hour and 20 minutes away so we
rent an apartment in Shreveport as well
so we had talked about buying something
like a little town home there because
his kids live
in Shreveport so this is our second
marriage so you don't have two mortgages
so you would go so you don't now we're
renting and we want to preserve our
credits so that we can go into debt and
we want our kids to get a debt go into
debt so that they can get into debt so
that why so they can build their scores
so they can get into debt why would they
build their score because we could build
our score and we if we're in debt we can
build our score and then we can go into
debt
this whole FICO thing is a dog chasing
its tail
it's designed for the banks by the Banks
to prosper only the banks
so if you're not going to go into debt
if you're not going to teach your kids
to go get a car loan if you're not going
to teach your kids that debt is a
survival mechanism because see your FICO
score is a zero indication of your net
worth
I can hand you a million dollars today
it does not change your stupid credit
score one iota
your income could go to a million
dollars a year it does not change your
credit score it is not an indicator of
Financial Health it's an indicator of
how much you play kissy face with the
bank
that's it that's all it's for yeah so
it's for so if they want to buy a house
and they had zero credit score I think
you did that George uh you know what
it's the very first video that launched
on my YouTube channel today Stacy you
can't I mean now it's not even a pitch
but it's right there you got to go pull
up George Campbell on YouTube and you
and your husband watch it tonight and
then send it to the kids you don't need
a credit score to buy a house
even if you're borrowing money even if
you're borrowing money it's called
manual underwriting I'll walk you
through it in that video on the YouTube
channel but it's real simple and I did
it myself once you're out of debt about
six to 12 months later the credit score
disappears you close all the accounts
and then you go through this process you
need a good down payment you need to
have your income you need to have your
W-2s a little more paperwork but it
really didn't break my back and I got a
great interest rate because I had a good
down payment on a 15-year fixed rate I
recommend your kids do the same if they
want to build wealth
or they could be 52 in debt hanging on
to their blankie it's up to that it's up
to them
I mean but he did
at the bank but ask some and he asked
the financial person at the place he
works at the car dealership he works at
and she said do not get rid of it I mean
she she said your credit score will go
way down don't do it it's worth the 50
points on your credit score to pay 250 a
year and I totally disagreed
but I said well I'm going to ask Dave
Ramsey I'm going to call David do some
of your own research I mean I can just
tell you the algorithm on the way the
the way FICO Works we've been trashing
FICO for years they would have come back
and haunted Us by now if we weren't
telling the truth goes to FICO yeah it's
uh don't don't worship at the altar of
the great FICO and a finance manager to
car dealership's just a dumb Banker
I mean that's all they couldn't get a
job at a bank their incentive and motive
is to get you into debt and keep you in
depth deal with people in debt all day
long
but they just want you in debt they lost
hope a long time ago all the time and so
yeah they worship at the altar of the
FICO so a 40-point move a two two-point
move on a FICO scares them to death
because they Worship the Great FICO when
you have a zero FICO score and you pay
cash
you um don't worship there anymore this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here when's
the last time you were excited about a
Monday
What If instead of waking up exhausted
you felt exhilarated
can't wait to get to work another day to
do what you love
in a world where bare minimum Monday
has taken the place of quiet quitting
it's clear that people are craving work
that matters meaningful work but finding
the career you were born to do can be
really hard if you don't have the right
tools that's why career and work expert
Ramsey personality Ken Coleman created
the get clear assessment it's incredible
assessment it'll help you discover your
top talents passions a clear mission
statement to help you find the work the
world needs you to do after taking the
quick assessments you'll get a custom
Report with everything you need to do to
take the first step towards a meaningful
career I took this it was pretty amazing
how much it nailed me I mean it's really
well done it just completely read my
mail yeah it's not not like I was
looking for work but it was just I took
it to test it as a validation as the CEO
of this place and I went oh good
assessment kind of figured things out
yeah start your journey take the get to
clear assessment today go to
ramseysolutions.com get clear you can
get it in the store at Ramsey Liz is
with us in Anaheim California hi Liz
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi there can y'all hear me okay
okay absolutely what's up
super nervous so sorry no trouble I
really appreciate talking to you both
and uh I was in Jade's Zoom class
awesome thank you good good good and uh
Mr Ramsey you helped bring me back to
God so wow well I'm honored yeah yeah
um okay so I'm just gonna read my
question because I'm so nervous
um so I have about 17 000 in debt about
halfway through my debt snowball who
started last year
um I uh let's see my parents offered to
pay my debt off
and then I would pay them back when I'm
able to should I go ahead and take this
offer but my thing is my parents we have
a strained relationship we butt heads a
lot they don't agree with the Ramsey
plan uh even though I've been following
it and they wouldn't have me continue to
ties to my church if I were to kind of
do this with them so
I'm not sure what to do yeah yeah you
know you know exactly what to do
yeah
don't you
I think so yeah what should you do
just continue with what I've been doing
yeah and just tell them thank you but I
love you but I gotta do this on my own
you're exactly right you're a sweet girl
you are your sweet lady thank you for
having a good heart the way you do
um you you have reached a point in your
life that you're now a grown-up
they're no longer your mommy and daddy
um no they're your parents they're now
your parents
my kid my kids are grown like that too
they're they actually have opinions that
I don't always agree with can you
imagine that
and you know what but and you know what
I still love them and they still love me
and they're allowed to do that and still
be in the family and all that kind of
stuff I don't get to control whether
they how they handle their money nor do
I want to I don't get to control uh
whether they tithe at their church I
don't get to control their spiritual
decisions uh I would obviously have an
opinion about all of it but it doesn't
matter yeah I got opinions about George
too but he gets to make his own
decisions he's an independent adult and
uh we're friends we can have a good
discussion we can have an argument even
um a fun argument sometimes we do that
George and I do and Rachel and I do my
kid you know everybody that's all okay
to do but that's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about control
yeah
and I don't borrow money from family on
principle if they said they wanted to
gift it even with the strings attached I
wouldn't take it and so it went from a
bad idea to a terrible idea real quick
and the truth is you don't need them
you're going to pay this off fast you've
been doing the hard work it's giving you
dignity to do the plan on your own
without having to do this weird reverse
allowance thing to your parents who
already have a strained relationship
with and it's only going to hurt the
relationship if you take that money yeah
it is it's going to make it worse not
better and they're they're trying to be
nice but they're trying to influence you
to do what they want you to do rather
than rather than letting you be a
grown-up and that's a Control Function
is what that is and they mean well I
don't think they're bad people I'm not
saying that at all but you can't let uh
folks interrupt your spiritual walk
interrupt your financial decisions
you can learn and you can have
discussions but you can't let people
have control over those things
regardless of what they do so George is
right even if it was a gift if it had no
tithing and um we're not going to do any
financial plan you agree with which
happens to be ours in this case then um
that's a Control Function and that's
what you've got to stay away from so you
you already knew what you're needed to
do you just it but then say this out
loud Liz here's what's interesting I can
hear your voice I can hear it in your
voice
if you took this money
you would feel like you were eight years
old
oh yeah I still feel like that a lot
anyway with them yeah and that they they
they return you to your childhood and so
uh the reason I I could hear it in the
way they're trying to control and trying
to Lord over you and um yeah I've had to
learn that here at the office with my
son work working here and my daughter
Rachel obviously on the air with me I've
had to learn if I'm going to argue with
them I cannot argue in my dad voice I
have to argue in my friend that is
arguing voice
that's a different tone isn't it yeah
yeah there's nothing demeaning in that
tone that's just like you and your buddy
over coffee or a beer having an argument
right and that's kind of a fun thing
almost uh it's a joyful kind it's a
conflict searching for truth it's not a
conflict searching for control
yeah yeah that eight-year-old thing
tells you the truth right there
yeah
yeah oh yeah
and you're what 25
32 turning 33 this month
are you are you are you single
I'm single
okay have you ever been married
no my sister just got married actually a
few weeks ago that's wonderful okay
okay I was just wondering what I was
probing at is if you had been through
something that hurt maybe and that this
was an open air open area in your
emotions I'm not Dr John deloney believe
me but um yeah you just sound like a
very kind sweet person that is trying to
find your own footing and this is a
really big step emotionally
even if even if this made you a
bazillion dollars and it doesn't
it's not worth it's not worth the payoff
yeah so you're very kind and I would
just be that Mom and Dad I love you
thank you so much you know I think it's
going to be good for me I've decided
I've decided it's good for me to work my
way through this and I'm going to do
that but I appreciate and I appreciate
you cheering for me on the sidelines
yeah and just say that and just keep on
trucking kiddo you're gonna be out of
debt in a year you're amazing you've
already done a great job how much has
your life changed in one year wow
all right let's do it we'll get it
scheduled I'll hold on and make sure you
talk to Austin before you leave so he
gets your so you can get to him and make
sure you get your debt free stream set
up and you remind us of this
conversation when you're doing the
scream okay
all right all right kiddo way to go wow
very cool I'm proud of her that's very
neat
it's a hard thing to do yeah moms and
dads it's a very difficult thing uh I
think I think George
um it's the most difficult stage of
parenting
having uh your children become adults
and I hate that phrase I I was writing
it in a blog thing I was doing the other
day about work and
um adult children
I still don't know what to call my kids
my kids that are adults because they're
your kids they're not kids they're not
children they're adults my offspring
that are adults I mean you know I mean
what do you call because adult children
sounds like an oxymoron yeah doesn't it
and so you've got to moms and dads
you've got to
um man well the goal I got it's hard
it's hard to not just at Easter dinner
not to go you know that's a dumb butt
thing I've ever heard in my life but you
just sit there adults you know I
wouldn't say that to one of my friends
and so I'm not going to say that to a
grown
Offspring
or whatever they are
I love it I think Mag Meeker said it you
know the goal is to raise adults not
kids yeah raise functioning adults not
functioning children that's Andy Andrews
actually there we go I knew it was one
of your friends this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage John and Courtney are with us hey
guys how are you treating you better
than I deserve where do you guys live
we live in Blairstown New Jersey which
is about an hour Northwest of Newark New
Jersey okay cool good to have you guys
welcome to Tennessee and here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off
169 900 I love it how long did this take
29 months way to go and your range of
income during that time approximately
160 000 to 190 000. wow very nice
incomes what do you guys do for a living
I am a speech language pathologist and I
work in law enforcement ah very good
very cool what kind of debt was the 170.
uh there was some credit cards a solar
loan a car a truck and student loans
y'all were normal yeah but you figured
out normal sucks yes yes all right we're
not normal anymore you're weird now way
to go so what happened to you guys 29
months ago what got you started on all
this Ramsey stuff so we actually came
down to Nashville in October of 2019 and
I attended the business Boutique
conference oh yeah and I took a picture
with Christy Wright posted it on
Facebook and one of John's co-workers
Darwin actually reached out to us and
said you're Dave people you're taking
people
who's Dave I came to see Christy
so uh yeah I asked him uh who's Dave and
he went into that he's following your
program and then I think him and his
wife actually came down in February of
and he sent me a text message asking if
he bought me a book would I read it and
I asked him what book and he said The
Total Money Makeover and I said sure if
you buy it I'll read it and uh February
2020 we wow what timing yeah we read the
book and then we're get all set for
March of 2020 to start the snowball and
then the world shut down and uh but we
still managed to work through it and
here we are I don't guess it's shut down
in law enforcement no it did not it
should be Speech Pathology shut down so
I was out of work for a couple weeks I
have my own practice so that was more by
choice than by any sort of law or
anything and was doing a lot of
Telehealth
okay wow well you got options when
you're self-employed yes you can
apparently we learned that you can just
decide if you're essential
it was interesting so hey way to call
you guys so right in the middle of a dad
blame pandemic you decide you're going
to get out of debt so did you put it on
hold or did you plow on WE plowed on
once you got on the horse you're gonna
ride huh okay cool very cool so did the
pandemic work in your favor because of
extra hours or hold you back because of
reduced income
I don't think it really did either other
than motivate us seeing that what could
happen and why we should have better
handle on our money yeah um but I did
take on an extra job during the pandemic
and have kept going since I teach uh
graduate level students via zoom in the
evenings when our son is sleeping that's
a great gig way to go hey just for the
uh for the listening audience uh because
a lot of folks that have uh graduate
level degrees like you do can do that
and make some good money do you mind
telling people what you get paid for
that I make about 35 000 a year doing
that wow and you teach one class a year
or two wow when your kid's asleep
that's a nice side hustle very nice side
you guys are incredible I thought that
was going to be the case that's why I
dug in yeah so you were throwing over
like half your income at this debt what
kind of sacrifices were you guys making
how did you do this especially living in
you know a higher cost of living area
where most people would say you can't do
this where I live
I don't really feel like we felt like we
sacrificed that much I always thought we
overspent kind of generally speaking
um but once we made the budget and
focused oh we make great money let's
just put it to use paying off debt
instead of getting more exactly you
don't realize how much nickel and diming
uh you do when you're not focused on
your budget and when you actually Bear
down and focus on it you realize okay
well I spent ten dollars here twenty
dollars there and it all adds up at the
end of the month so The Total Money
Makeover you read that and then you just
listen to the podcast and did this yes
listened religiously even our son asked
us one day that if he marries a girl who
has student loans he now will have debt
right wow that's incredible he's already
picking out his shots
this is great you need to find this out
in the third grade do you have debt yet
no
good stuff very very cool all right what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
feel like it's so cliche but definitely
the budget I definitely think it's also
uh celebrating the wins in the beginning
with the smaller loans like you see it a
lot faster you're paying off paying off
paying off and uh you know you see the
loans disappear off our spreadsheet and
then once they got a little bit bigger
and it took you know longer to pay a
single debt off
uh once we got to the end of it you know
we we kind of celebrated either with
like a sushi lunch as our son loves to
have uh or uh you know something like
that just just to keep the motivation
going
yeah your son has good taste that free
girls and Sushi yeah he definitely does
how old is he seven he's seven he's
going places he's going places he's got
he's got a big future ahead of him very
cool so when you're reading through The
Total Money Makeover or you're listening
to the podcast what was the primary
thing that made you say we've got to do
this
I feel like for a long time I had
suggested to John that we budget in some
way not specifically the snowball or
anything like that but
um he usually always found a reason why
we needed to spend the different money
that we spent but once he read the book
he was very much on board and and I said
you understand what this means we like
can't go on vacation we have to sell
everything that we don't use he's like
yes I understand wow so for you what
what was the thing that turned you
around on this
um
I don't know I just uh wanted to retires
the millionaire and not have to ever
worry about money again so long-term
Vision yeah you bought the belief that
you really can live like no one else and
later live and give like no one else
absolutely so you came to Nashville to
celebrate what else you're doing to
celebrate uh we're doing a pool
renovation right now
um so hopefully when we get back the
contract we'll be starting that uh the
week or so yeah be ready be ready by the
time the weather's warm in Jersey yes
very good very cool good for you guys
very proud of y'all great work hey we've
got the live and give box for you it's
got The Total Money Makeover book in it
which you can give away that's what got
your journey started and of course the
baby steps millionaires book which is
the next step in your journey and the
financial peace membership as well to go
through Financial Peace University
either use it or give it away it's the
live and give box all right let's bring
this young genius up uh you said he's
seven years old what's his name Giovanni
Giovanni all right very good he loves
Sushi and debt-free girls this guy's
crushing the game that's very good he's
killing it already good good good lineup
John and Courtney 170
000 paid off in 29 months making 160 to
190. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
[Applause]
I love it that's how it's supposed to be
done George incredible
and regardless of where people are at
because they may look at this amazing
couple and go well Dave I don't make 160
Grand or I have more there's always an
excuse people have to not do the plan
and I I love what John said where he
just went I looked at the facts and I
realized I need to be thinking longer
than what's happening this weekend and
think about what is the next five years
10 years 20 years look like and
regardless of your income you got to
make a decision you're going to be there
10 years from now so where do you want
to be yep you're going you're going to
do something you're going to work for 10
years where are you going to end up
because you're going to do the work you
might as well get the prize you know run
as Paul says run in such a way that you
get the prize you know it's you have to
push on through and do this it's the the
moral of the story on hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds now I guess
thousands of debt free screams on
YouTube is
you can do it
yeah talking to you
you're out there riding around your car
right now you're on the treadmill you're
going for a run
talking to you
when are you gonna decide to change your
entire life
and go through the process of starting
with becoming debt free so that you can
Bill wealth so that you can be
outrageously generous
it puts you in a whole new place boys
and girls
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day James 5 13 is
anyone among you in trouble
let them pray
is anyone happy let them sing songs of
praise
Abraham Lincoln says I have been driven
many times to my knees by the
overwhelming conviction that I had
nowhere else to go
he's got away with words that's fabulous
oh Taylor is with us in Auburn Alabama
Hey Taylor welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave and George thank you for having
me on sure what's up
so my wife and I for first nine years of
marriage got all the way to baby step
six and uh change of jobs stepped into
Ministry four kids and 10 years later
got 7 700 of credit card debt and a 7
700 credit card or excuse me a uh car
payment as well
and just knowing wanting to know what to
attack first should I stop retirement to
start paying these things off our budget
is stretched and it just seems like
there's not a whole lot of options
yes I would definitely pause investing
how much are you investing right now
right now it's 350 a month
that's 350 more to throw at the debt how
much other money do you have to throw
extra on top of the minimum payments
putting we Ed 400 in savings every month
too if we stop that we could we could
stop that and throw that at it as well
how much is in savings
eight thousand dollars right now it's
dwindled a lot
eight thousand dollars
yeah I wish it was a lot more okay just
making sure you didn't say 80. Okay
um what's your household income sir
thirty thousand dollars combined my wife
is a teacher I'm an executive director
profit Ministry
where's all your money going
18 year old a 15 year old a 12 year old
and a 10 year old
um we've got 225 000 left on a house
and we took a big step into building
that house
um purchase land and sold land and it
cost more to build than we anticipated
and so that's where a lot of the money
went originally and right now just with
four kids and life we've really stopped
eating out we've cut as many expenses as
we can we developed the budget got the
every dollar app
but it just doesn't seem life insurance
policies
uh four kids in four different schools
activities Etc
private schools
no four Public Schools but got kids that
do show choir and band and trumpet
rentals and uniforms travel
Etc
okay
um I still hadn't found 130 000 so are
you sure you and your wife are doing a
written Budget on every dollar and both
of you are agreeing for where every
dollar is going
we well we started this month oh I mean
oh okay totally honest I can tell you
over the last year year and a half no
you haven't been there's been money
going out the door in places that we're
going man you know car expenses getting
the oil changed
three cars one needs a new set of tires
I mean there's just all kinds of things
but the way you keep describing all of
the way you keep describing all this is
not executing a budget it all sounds
like chaos
yes it's managing you you're not
managing it that's the the way you're
verbal pattern is coming off okay so
yeah I think you guys need to get on a
really really
detailed in depth with the television
off and the kids in another room
detailed budget the junior wife are
really looking at and saying this month
how here's what's coming in this month
here is what it's going to exactly
and I think there's more room in this
budget then uh you than you've described
and you may have to cut back on some
things that are kid projects I don't
know but that that's something you all
will look at and decide but um but you
know you've got a thousand dollars a
month we know right there and once you
get the piece
and the control that that detailed
budget will give you you'll be able to
release seven of the 8 000 and start
working the baby steps again so stop all
savings stop all anything you're right
back at baby step one you need a
thousand dollars and then everything
else goes on your other stuff so sounds
like we're going to pay off one of these
uh 7 700 debts there's two debts that
are 7 700.
yeah they're exactly the same amount
right now
um obviously the credit card's much
higher percentage would you start at
that one and then move to the car
payment yeah all things being equal I'll
choose the percentage and it sounds like
they're equal one single credit card
uh one single credit card yes sir okay
all right yeah I think I'm getting rid
of that and have a thousand dollars in
the bank and uh and that's month one
and then month two is we're aggressively
attacking the car and getting rid of it
and then month three is we rebuild the
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses that's baby step three
uh and you're gonna be there by
Christmas
okay that's where you should be
mathematically
um and I think you could be there sooner
because I can't
um you know make sure you haven't got a
bunch of stuff coming out of your check
at work are you getting a big tax refund
now uh paid Federal 317 and uh got 2 000
back from State that's about right then
okay all right good there's a lot of
money leaks happening I I would stop the
uh over over withholding on the state if
you have the ability to adjust the state
without withholding without adjusting
the federal I would I don't know how
your state functions on that but I try
to do that because you're obviously over
withholding a couple hundred bucks a
month on State
and um yeah that's that that right
there's a thousand bucks we found
between those three things to get
started on this which means in seven
months the car the other cars oh yeah
and you freed up the credit card
payments you're gonna throw that on top
of it that's true tell the snowball
rules so I think you can do this in six
months easily yeah and the emergency
fund too I think there's more room than
a thousand dollars in there that you
should find
um but you know you just start looking
for nickels and dimes and then when you
get the emergency fund rebuilt that's
baby step three then you're back to four
five and six and four is you're putting
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement five is kids college savings
if you're doing that you need to stop it
for a little while until you get this
mess cleaned up and
um what caused you guys to do this is
you were uh not working a plan not
working a system and everything happened
to you instead of you happening to hit
the house being overbuilt uh the
purchase decisions that didn't that you
didn't have the money to buy instead of
saying no you bought them anyway and you
know and that's the stuff happening to
you instead of you happening to hit
money is a wonderful slave but it's a
terrible master
that'll preach that's amazing what
happens and you start paying attention
and going oh we could do better there we
could do better there we can cut that
let's get rid of the whole life let's
get term and all of a sudden you just
find a thousand bucks in your budget
another thousand yeah there's probably
two thousand making 130 Grand yeah I'd
find another thousand if I were you yeah
I think there's twenty four thousand a
year out of 130 that you can get your
hands on to clean this mess up and to
rebuild right quickly to worry about
this time next year you know you you
could be aggressively putting into kids
college if that's in K in places I guess
some teens you got to get ready for that
and
um you know you'll have your emergency
fund in place and you have no payments
but your house payment and that house
payment's not completely out of control
with 130 000 income it's really not your
problem but this out of control thing is
what your problem is you've been tail
spinning on the ice for a while and um
you can hear it it's amazing to me that
people make six figures and they're
still living paycheck to paycheck and
the data is showing us this that there's
increasing numbers of people making six
figures still vast majority of them over
80 percent and everyone's blaming
inflation and all these things but
really if they're out of control
spending yeah he wasn't blaming anything
he was blaming himself which is that's a
healthy thing not to shame yourself but
to just to say okay recognize I'm the
I'm the problem and therefore I'm the
solution and our behaviors are the
problem our chaos is the problem so the
solution is push the chaos out with
systems and processes very deliberate
hustle and grind leaning in very
detailed and you you know that's how you
work you know you just work the process
just work the system just work the
system just work the system and then all
of a sudden things start to come into
control and there's margin emotionally
there's margin relationally there's
margin spiritually and there's margin
mathematically it all starts to come but
you have to you have to impose your will
on life or it will impose its will on
you that's the one of the best days of
your life looking back is when you
realize oh I'm the problem I can fix
that yep it is it's very very empowering
it's not shaming at all so good stuff
man thanks for calling in Taylor that's
a really good question excellent
excellent excellent
George Campbell good show today that
puts this hour of the rims he's showing
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there is ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]